plenty of the world's best comedians
have been fired from Saturday Night Live
over the past 30 years including Adam
Sandler Chris Rock and Shane Gillis but
nothing compares to the huge mistake SNL
made when they fired Norm Macdonald from
Weekend Update in 1998. Norm is
considered by many to be the funniest
Weekend Update host of all time as he
joked about everything that was
happening during the mid 90s from
sporting events to Global Affairs but
there is one specific topic that Norm
loved to joke about the most so often in
fact it ended up costing him his job and
that topic was O.J Simpson during the
height of the OJ trials Norma hundreds
of hilarious jokes surrounding the viral
news story that was sweeping the country
but unfortunately for Norm the president
of NBC at the time Don olmeyer was close
personal friends with OJ and ended up
firing Norm Macdonald for the jokes he
was making about the juice this might
sound unbelievable but Don omire has
fired